our set also includes a third volume
diss Atlas France Waze which in which we
found an extraordinary thing and out
just we found this pen the France Waze
Atlas had never been used for 200 years
in the pen was just tucked in to one of
the charts and it when we started
putting the whole story of the atlas
together we realized that what had
happened the atlas came to me through a
London auction and the atlas had been
captured in a battle and this is the
annotation by the owner WP Williams he
captured it in a battle off the coast of
brittany off the island of shaw on nova
on August 10th 1780 he had a battle with
the French frigate the nymph and the
British were the victors in this the
French captain was killed the ship the
friendship was captured and they
captured these three atlases they
considered the atlases so important they
were like you know tools of war so they
kept the atlases and then they passed
down through Williams family and then
came to me through auction but what we
think is Williams never used the French
volume it's sat undisturbed and the pen
we think is the French captain's pen and
he made these notes on the chart here on
the day he died showing his route over
to the battle so these are the kinds of
things that just gets our hair what
little we have left of it standing up
and exciting and it's all part of the
provenance of and the story of these
amazing books the quality of the
engraving here that Belen did is
exceptional
[Music]